So we know a game icon should give
people an idea of your game content.
But screenshots let you
show them in detail.
The best screenshots show what's
unique and fun about your game.
Here are some good screenshots
from the game Temple Run.
The very first image is of the main
character running away from something
into a temple.
It shows all the main aspects of
the game, a character who runs and
collects coins, with a clean visual.
The second image emphasizes a detail,
the coins that we saw in the first
image, and the text hopefully
explains what they do.
And the third screenshot
shows a special feature.
And you'll notice that all of
these images have some text that
helps describe the images.
In general you'll want to
communicate visually, but
it's okay to have some supporting text
that doesn't take away from the image.
After someone looks
at your screen shots,
if they're still on the fence,
they'll read your game description.
The description should be clear and
short and
talk about your game's main features.
For example, Temple Run's description
gives a bit of back story
about the player running away from
demon monkeys and collecting coins, and
then goes on to describe how to
play the game with swipes and taps.
It describes the gameplay,
goals, and obstacles.
So use your screenshots and
description wisely to describe gameplay,
goals, and obstacles.